les intempéries montpellier et toute une
partie du département de l'hérault et de
celui du gard sont encore sonnés 24
heures après le mur d'eau qui s'est
abattu sur la région
pas de victime mais plusieurs dizaines
d'évacuation aujourd'hui on a sorti les
sauts et les feuilles d'assurance yann
fronty car incomati et des dégâts chez
vous comme tous les habitants de
montpellier ce couple a été surpris par
les inondations 18h30 hier un gros orage
s'abat sur la ville sur des parkings
nous inonder des voitures prisonnière de
la cus semble flotter à la surface
les pompiers eux multiplient les
interventions et les opérations de
sauvetage les personnes coincées dans
leur véhicule ou sur le toit des
véhicules s'étaient engagés dans les
endroits où l'eau est montée assez
rapidement donc on allait les plongeurs
surtout ont été engagés pour les
secourir la victime sur les doigts des
véhicules à quelques kilomètres de là la
ville de sommières dans le gard
ici le maire est sur la brèche même sur
le pont angoissé il part régulièrement
inspecté le niveau de la rivière qui
menace de déborder
et m 70 auteurs alain dany les cherche à
éviter ce qu'il s'est passé le week-end
dernier de grosses inondations et la
mort d'un pompier en opération alors ce
soir
il est aux aguets d'ici deux heures on
aura pratiquement atteint la cote dakota
maximale qui à mon avis devrait se
situer aux alentours de 80 être fausse
alerte finalement l'orage et moins
violents que prévu aviv cru du vide où
il ya le mini passé tout le monde peut
alors se coucher sommières a été épargné